hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review show and it's still
march so we're doing monster march and
uh in this one gonna do a little bit of
a different kind of monster uh one that
was maybe i don't know i kind of feel
like it was more original back then but
they've had other ones like this since
since that time i kind of feel like this
is sort of maybe where
m night shyamalan got the idea for the
happening which was also kind of about
killer plants which this one is as well
i don't know maybe it's not as rare as
i'm thinking it is uh this is the 1962
film the day of the trifids
now i had seen this
uh probably three or four times as a kid
and i noticed that it was on 2b for free
so i decided to watch it now i don't
know if this is the case or not i was
watching another review of this movie
and they said that this movie much like
knight of the living dead the original
george romero classic from 1968 had
fallen into the public domain i don't
know if that's true or not but it is all
over youtube for free
and nobody seems to be taking it down so
that could be the case have to say
though even though i watched a more
quote unquote official version on to be
like with ads and everything uh the
print looks like ass it looks really bad
and like some of the um shots toward the
end are just like really washed out like
on the bottom it just looks really
really bad so i'm imagining uh because
this is a fairly well-known like sci-fi
british sci-fi from this era so i
probably i mean it's probably been
restored at some stage and like put out
on at least dvd if not blu-ray uh but
just know that if you want to watch it
for free you totally can but it doesn't
really look all that good like the
colors are all washed out it just looks
really shitty so i haven't seen the
restored version
now this is actually a an adaptation a
very loose adaptation which i'll get
into in a bit of a novel by john wyndham
which came out in 1951. i haven't read
the original novel of this i have read
some of john wyndham's other stuff uh
he'd be you know very well known uh
british writer of you know sci-fi horror
type stuff uh i think i read one of his
novellas when i was a kid out of the
depths i think it was called which was
actually really good but i did read a
synopsis of this because i was curious
to see like how different this movie was
than the uh than the book and uh yeah
it's a lot different
so uh yeah we'll get into that so this
movie uh as i said it's a british film
and uh the director was steve cicelli
cicely i think is how you pronounce his
last name i think that was like a
pseudonym actually i think that he was
like hungarian and uh with some
assistance from freddy francis and if
you know anything about british cinema
then you'll know the name freddy francis
he directed a [ __ ] ton of uh
of uh hammer films and did he do some
amicus ones as well i want to say he did
some amicus ones i could be way off on
that but for sure he did a lot of hammer
films
so what you have basically what the
story of this is there's a meteor shower
at the very beginning
and uh so you're led to believe that
what
eventually become the trifids or the
killer plants
uh came to earth as spores like on these
meteors that hit the earth right now
that's very very different than the book
like i said i'll get into that uh in a
little bit because you know there's a
whole other thing like trifids it's
funny because triffids have they act
like in the movie like this is an actual
plant and it's just like oh it's mutated
and stuff it's not really john wyndham
actually invented it like for the book
but
it's this story was so kind of
ubiquitous or well-known
that
even i believe to this day like any kind
of like big invasive plant is still
known as a trifid it's just you know
what i mean like colloquially but it's
not an actual plant like they do kind of
make you think that it is in the in the
uh movie
so yeah so there's a meteor shower and
then we're kind of jumping back and
forth between two story lines now the
story line that you have with the
husband and wife scientists
i don't think that that was in the
original novel what i heard again i'm
not entirely sure if this is the case
but i've seen this mentioned on a couple
of different uh reviews and sources
that said that the stuff that they did
the more kind of road trip stuff that
they did with the navy officer
and the little girl and everything like
that which again i'll get into in a
minute was they shot all that and it
wasn't long enough so then they had to
add this other kind of like subplot with
these two like bickering husband and
wife scientists who
spoiler alert eventually end up how you
know finding out accidentally like how
to destroy the triffids which again does
not happen in the book this is very very
war of the world and john windham even
said well when he wrote the novel that
you know he acknowledged you know he
didn't say this is my version of war of
the worlds but he said this is very very
influenced by war of the worlds because
he was really into that book and so this
was kind of like his take on it
so uh so you have these two scientists
the guy the male scientist is a complete
uh
jerk and an alcoholic
and i guess there's some type him and
his wife are some type of
i don't they're like marine biologists
or something like that because she says
something about you know we have to
finish dissecting that manta ray or
whatever the hell she said it was
something like that like a sea creature
and he's just like i'll get a [ __ ] about
[ __ ] stink it was a stingray i don't
give a [ __ ] about stingrays anymore i
guess this is so boring i'm so bored
with everything blah blah blah and he's
just like a real like ray of sunshine to
be around
and there's this one i don't know why
this scene made me like laugh so much
but like in a in a like sad laugh kind
of way where he was just kind of like
where's you know the booze i guess
because they're they're doing uh they're
doing research like on this really
really remote uh island lighthouse kind
of situation
and so they only get a boat that comes
like once a week with supplies
so i guess he only gets a bottle of
scotch or whatever his uh liquor of
choice is once a week and he's not not
real happy about it so
so he says he yells at his wife like
where'd you hide it this time and she's
like honey it's in the same cabinet that
it's always in and he's just like oh
yeah you know what i hate it i was just
kind of like oh boy here we go but yeah
he's just like way like over
yeah and she's just very like meek and
just kind of like you can tell she's
kind of like sick of this [ __ ] but she's
just like used to dealing with it and
like used to managing him and stuff
but yeah he's just kind of like i don't
you know i'm sick of doing i'm sick of
the science i'm sick of this and i'm
sick of you and it's like i don't even
want to be on this [ __ ] island
anymore and [ __ ] like that and he's just
having a big [ __ ] mantra about it and
so she's basically like okay fine we'll
leave tomorrow we'll release all our
specimens back in the wild she's like
this was your idea by the way but okay
so you have that subplot going on
and then you have kind of the main
subplot which is the one that is taken
from the book
and that concerns a dude named bill
mason who i think is like a navy officer
or something like that
now they show him he wakes up in the
hospital and he has just had presumably
eye surgery i don't think because i did
watch this a couple of times but i don't
think they mentioned what the eye
surgery was for which is really
interesting because in the book
his eyes were [ __ ] up because of
something relating to the plot but
that's not that's neither here nor there
like i said i'll get into like the
differences between the book and the
movie later yeah so he wakes up in the
hospital with his eyes all bandaged and
so they established through like the
doctor and the nurse coming in there and
talking to him and he's like why can't i
get so all the dudes in this are really
really funny
why why can't i take the the bandages
off now they're coming off at eight in
the morning anyway uh because they're
supposed to be this big amazing like
meteor shower and he's kind of pissed
that he won't be able to see it because
he has bandages over his eyes and his
doctor's like no no no you're supposed
to leave the bandages on for the whole
10 days you have him taken off at 8 00
in the morning and he's just like
ryan he's like all cranky about it and
he's like you know so there's that
now uh so what ends up happening though
is that so he falls asleep and then the
next morning he kind of like over sleeps
and he hears the clock uh you know kind
of chiming outside and he's like oh it's
nine in the morning they were supposed
to come and take this [ __ ] bandages
off my eyes what the hell's going on so
he starts calling out for like the nurse
and the doctor nobody answers and so
he's just like what the [ __ ] is going on
like nobody's answering and he's getting
all like [ __ ] ragey and [ __ ] and so
finally he's just like [ __ ] it and he
takes off the bandages himself because
it was just like wrapped around his head
it wasn't like all it wasn't like all
fancy or anything so he just takes them
off and he's just like oh yeah like i
guess the surgery worked i can see i
know it was lasik or whatever they
didn't have that back then
but yeah so uh so he's like oh yeah i
can see but he's like where the [ __ ] is
everybody so then he goes out into the
hallway and there's like nobody around
and everything's like all [ __ ] up and
like knocked over and stuff uh fun fact
in case you're thinking that my
description of this they're like wow
that sounds like 28 days later yeah um
that's exactly where uh danny boyle i
believe got the idea i think he actually
did say that he was inspired or the guy
that wrote was it danny boyle or was the
guy that wrote this screenplay for 28
days later i can't remember now wait did
danny boyle write the screenplay now i
can't remember but yeah he did say that
he got the idea for 28 days later from
this scene in day of the trophies where
the dude wakes up and like he can't find
anybody in the hospital and he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] is going on
so finally he's like
you know stumbling around the hospital
being like this is [ __ ] crazy and
there's like nobody here
and then finally this guy like comes up
and and jump scares his ass and this is
dr soames who was his doctor
dr soames is kind of like looking out of
the distance and [ __ ] and he's you know
the guy's like what the [ __ ] he's like
what the hell is going on
and um he's like can you take me to my
office please and he's like okay and so
he takes him to his office and then he's
like shining a light in his eyes he's
like yep i can't see like my optic nerve
is fried and he says basically what
happened while you were sleeping and
with bandages over your eyes is that
everybody that went outside to watch the
meteor shower is now blind it like
burned out their optic nerves so uh
apparently people all over the world
most people were watching this amazing
meteor shower therefore most of the
people in the world are now blind
uh which is not a good situation uh so
at this point uh he's just kind of like
holy [ __ ] that's amazing but obviously
he can still see because he had bandages
over his eyes and he didn't see the
meteor shower
and so then the doctor's like hey can
you just go over there for just a minute
and like give me my bag or whatever and
then while his back is turned the doctor
like jumps out the [ __ ] window and
commits suicide bill is all what the
[ __ ] okay so he's like well i'm gonna go
back to my ship and see what the hell is
going on so he goes out into the streets
of london and obviously everybody is
walking around like they're blind you
know what i mean like not everybody but
most people are so you know you get most
of the people kind of like wandering
around like that and every now and then
you have somebody that can see like
leading some other people around but
everybody's just kind of like what the
[ __ ] and like nobody's driving and it's
like everything just like went to [ __ ]
in one night presumably
and so he actually goes to a train
and the train ends up crashing i guess
because the engineer was like i can
still see and then he's like oh wait no
i can't and then he like crashed it now
i just like it so people keep piling out
nobody can see everybody's flipping out
and then this little girl named susan
gets out and she can still see but
apparently she doesn't really know what
the [ __ ] is going they didn't have like
you know smartphones or nothing like
that so some of the people are like slow
on the uptake i guess of like what the
news was um and don't realize that
almost everybody in the world is blind
so she gets off the train and uh she's
kind of like this woman comes up and is
like have you seen my son have you seen
my son she's like i haven't seen him and
she's like wait you can see and um she's
like hey this little girl can see and
then of course everybody like this guy
comes over you can see girly come on
you're coming with me and they try to
like take her like she's like they're
seeing eye child or something like that
it's [ __ ] up
so uh so bill sees this situation and he
intervenes and so uh him and the little
girl
they kind of start on this sort of
journey to first they want to go to the
dockyard because they hear a radio
message that um some of the people there
could see because they were in a
submarine and they didn't see the meteor
shower so
some of the people there could see so
they're like we're you know if you can
see like come here we need everybody's
help and [ __ ] like that so they start
kind of like making their way like
various places also
if as if it wasn't bad enough that the
meteors made everybody blind the meteor
apparently also brought these spores to
earth which start out as kind of like
little flowery looking doohickeys and
they uh seem like intelligent like
almost have sort of like animal
intelligence like they can move around
and [ __ ]
and as the movie goes on
they start getting bigger and bigger and
also they can uproot themselves and like
walk around and they can also uh shoot
like poison at people which kills them
now interestingly in the novel
uh the trifids did act did not actually
come from space triffids were actually
like a plant like uh an invasive and i
think bill mason or one or was he a
scientist i think i think in the book he
was a scientist and he was working on
triffids and then they start there was
like a mutator like it was like genetic
bioengineering and it was like they you
know it was 1951 so it was cold worship
so they thought like the russians had
bio-engineered these plants that could
like pull themselves up out of the
ground and like run around and eat
people
so they didn't come from space it was
like a scientific
mutation or something that might have
been done on purpose i think they left
it i think john wouldn't maybe left it
ambiguous as to whether the russians
actually did it or not but i think he
was like leaning toward that being the
case uh and what like i was saying
earlier bill he actually was in the
hospital at the beginning because one of
the triffids had sprayed like the acid
[ __ ] in his eyes so he needed like
surgery which to me like is a lot that
makes a lot more sense like i said i
haven't read the book but i read like
the synopsis of it and i'm like they
should have made this into the movie
because like the book seemed a lot
better but you know what i mean because
the movie's not terrible but
it's a little bit and i like a lot of
british uh horror and sci-fi from this
period it has like a weird like inert
kind of i don't know kind of energy to
it i'm not really sure if i am putting
that the right way i mean like cool [ __ ]
does happen uh the plant monsters like
the trifids you know they look a little
bit cheesy but they actually look pretty
cool um you know for like walking killer
plants that's that's pretty awesome and
there's like some good like kind of
creepy scenes in there
but i think it suffers too much the
movie adaptation at least from being too
similar to war of the worlds like having
kind of a pat ending because you know
how like at the end of the war of the
worlds they're like uh you know oh [ __ ]
humanity's doomed like all the [ __ ]
you know aliens are gonna kill us and
then it's like oh like a germ wiped them
out lucky yes you know what i mean uh
this has that same thing the book did
not end like that the book basically
ended like
the world totally went to [ __ ] these
autocratic like despotic governments
came in like you know came in and like
everyone was miserable and it's
suffering and the triffids were taken
over they couldn't figure out how to
kill them and uh and then they ended it
well well maybe one day we'll figure out
how to kill these [ __ ]
so the book had a lot more like bleaker
a lot more ambiguous ending whereas the
movie had more of a war of the worlds
ending where it was kind of like look
we've done everything like we tried
burning them and we tried chopping them
up and we tried doing this because like
when you chop them up then there's like
two of them you know what i mean so uh
so it's like we tried everything and
they're gonna take over holy [ __ ] it's
like you know it's the end of humanity
blah blah but then it so happens that
the [ __ ] scientist and his wife
you know at the last ditch effort you
know i mean when the plants are like
invading
they are since they're at the lighthouse
so they have this hose that sprays salt
water and it sprays salt water on them
and salt water kills them and they're
like woohoo problem solved it was right
in front of us all along you know what i
mean so
it does have a little bit of a cop-out
ending and you know and i and i can see
why they wanted to do that because like
i said where the world's ended like that
with like a very simple thing or
something that we take for granted being
the thing that killed them
but it does feel a little anti-climactic
i have to say
so so yeah the scientists do kind of
like factor in that's why that subplot
is there but the main plot like i said
is bill
and this little girl who's an orphan
and they're kind of like traveling
around trying to find so they go to this
one place like they go to france and
then they find this one house
where
everyone's kind of like they're they're
kind of like bringing people in because
there are some people there that can see
so they have it's some kind of like i
don't know what it is it was like some
kind of boarding house or a big mansion
or something like that so they have like
all these kind of like beds set up and
they have like all this food and you
know they're helping people out
so they go there but you know the the
triffids are still like getting up and
like invading and obviously since a lot
of people are blind shitty people who
can see are gonna take advantage so
there is one scene where
um where this house where all these
people are staying like it's invaded by
all these convicts and these convicts
can see because presumably they were in
prison and were not watching the meteor
shower so they can see so they come in
there and proceed to like force all the
blind girls in there to like dance with
them and there's also one scene where
one of the guys starts like dragging a
woman upstairs where she's like
screaming and freaking out where he's
obviously going to rape her
so there's all that going on too so you
know so bill and the little girl they
kind of and the good people that can see
like at this place have to kind of
gather people together like as the
plants are coming in and they have to
kind of get the [ __ ] out of there and
find some other place to go honestly one
of my favorite scenes in this like as
far as um
kind of the implication of it being like
frightening and everything is actually
quite near the beginning like not too
long after bill
uh finds susan the orphan who i think in
the book is actually not an orphan i
think he does find a little girl named
susan but he finds her alone like at a
house and like her brother has been
killed by the trifids so he kind of like
takes her under his wing like you know
father-daughter kind of thing and it's
like okay let's get the [ __ ] out of here
because she's all by herself so but
there's a scene like not too long after
he finds her and they find this you know
they find this place that has a radio
broadcast and it's in french and he
doesn't speak french but she does
because she has run away from a boarding
school so presumably they were teaching
her to speak french there and she tells
him what it says
and then they hear
these people that's like that are on
this airplane
and they're on it's like a passenger
airplane and the pilot and the co-pilot
and all the flight crew
went blind
and they're trying to like not panic all
the passengers by like not telling them
by the way
nobody can see where the [ __ ] we're
going so we can't see the land because
like i said this was
1962. i mean
i don't really know what plane flying
technology was like in 1962 i don't
think it's like nowadays where you don't
necessarily need human intervention like
unless something goes terribly wrong
but uh but yeah back then so
so they just keep telling all the
passengers most of whom are blind also
that it's like no no it's fine
everything's okay blah blah blah and
then all it takes is for this one little
kid to go is the pilot blind too and
then i was like god damn it kid and then
everybody starts flipping out you know
because they knew they were i mean the
pilot and the co-pilot like pretty much
knew they were gonna crash because they
tell like the the flight crew go back
there and tell them everything's gonna
be okay
implication being you know let them die
like happy so they don't know what's
coming like you know what i mean um but
then that kid like saying that out loud
like causes chaos and then like uh bill
and susan are like listening to this on
the radio
and the plane actually does crash like
not too far away from where they are
which is like pretty horrible i mean the
special effect doesn't look that great
it's basically like plane and then
there's like a green screen explosion or
whatever like over it but yeah i don't
know like the implication of it really
like bothered me
but yeah so i don't know like i said i
like a lot of british sci-fi from this
uh period this reminded me a lot of like
you know the quainter mass experiment or
something like that um again it's very
very war of the worlds and i just
thought it was interesting i don't know
i thought it was interesting how i guess
the subplot with uh the husband and wife
scientists that was added later
i mean i guess i understand why they
added that like to pat out the runtime
to
have scientists in there because i think
bill was a scientist in the book but in
this one they just made him like a navy
officer so they needed some scientists
in there to kind of try and figure out
what could kill these things
and so they had to be the ones to come
up with the solution albeit accidentally
like they didn't even mean to
but the weird thing about it is that i
kind of thought that with these two
storylines that they would have like
intersected at some point but they never
do so it's almost kind of like two
different
takes on the same event but they're
coming at it from like different so i
thought that was like a little bit
strange that they didn't like make the
effort maybe they shot most of the stuff
with bill and susan like they shot all
of that and they're like oh [ __ ] it's
only like an hour long we need like
another 20 minutes of footage and then
they just like cobbled together this
other
subplot i don't know if that's true or
not but i don't know that's hearing that
i was just kind of like well that kind
of makes sense because the two
they just kind of cut back and forth
between the two stories but they don't
like relate to one another really so
there is that so it's a little bit
disjointed but that said um it's
actually not a bad film like i said if
you're going to watch it on 2b i kind of
feel it's one that if you're into
british sci-fi from this era then you
should probably see it because it is
like quite well known i'm sure the book
is a lot better
um the book sounds a lot better at least
from the summary and like i said i've
read i haven't read that one but i've
read some john winton's other stuff and
he's actually a really good writer so i
imagine the book is like a lot more
interesting and like i said the book
actually doesn't really have like um
like an alien component because the the
plants the trifids are
like human bioengineered uh there is a
meteor shower in there but the meteor
shower is also supposedly like some
russian shenanigans so
it's more like a cold war type story or
like science gone awry type of story
rather than like an alien evasion story
from what i could determine so it's
interesting that they chose to do it
more like alien like i guess more like
war of the worlds in the movie now
they've made a [ __ ] ton of adaptations
of this uh not just movies they've done
all kind of different [ __ ] because like
i said this is a pretty iconic
sci-fi novel
so they've made i believe this was the
first film adaptation i think they did a
c uh serial like a like a limited series
mini series on the bbc in 1981 and i've
heard that one was actually pretty good
and like a lot more faithful to the book
although i haven't seen it although now
i'd be interested to see it to see like
how it matches up more with the book
because like i said i kind of feel like
i didn't mind like the scientist
characters i mean because they were kind
of i mean at least like the male
scientist was like really entertaining
because he was so aggro and like for a
reason and he was just like such a drunk
and everything and but i i thought it
was kind of like a cop-out how they
ended it's like oh we spray him with
salt water and that's how you kill them
is that how was that what happened in
the happening too like that m night
shyamalan i haven't seen it i know it's
about killer plants but
well no cause water killed the aliens in
signs that's what i was thinking of but
i just i haven't seen that happening so
i'm not really sure so anytime you're
doing something like that and they just
set it to m night shyamalan too like at
the end of science they're like really
water come on like i get it but
it's kind of like that and now that i'm
thinking about it if you guys ever seen
like the terrible terrible like z grade
50 sci-fi uh horror horror of party
beach horror of party beach salt water
or actually salt
ends up killing the aliens so
that seems to be like a thing in sci-fi
of that era where it's like something
like i said something really common that
everybody takes for granted like ends up
killing
i could see something like
i don't know maybe not salt water maybe
something that's like a little less
common than that i mean
water just like out of the tap killing
the aliens in signs that's just like
unforgivable because come on i mean the
[ __ ] planet is like three quarters
water you think they would have seen
that like when they were landing like oh
[ __ ] we shouldn't go there you know what
i mean but if it was something a little
more subtle
you know maybe not salt maybe like
paprika you know what i mean it's just
you know what i mean something like that
cinnamon uh kills them it's like
something you wouldn't immediately think
of or something that's common but not so
common that you would like think of it
first i don't know but yeah so it did
that did kind of piss me off especially
uh after i discovered that that's not
actually how the book ended the book
ended
pretty much with like uh the breakdown
of civilization to a large degree
um you know kind of like a walking dead
type situation and they're just kind of
like well one day we're gonna work on
figuring out how to kill these [ __ ]
things because they're taking over the
earth um and they just kind of left it
like that so i don't know it's it's hard
because you can't i feel like you can't
really win like if you leave the ending
ambiguous like that then everybody get
pissed off about that but then if you do
kind of like a pat easy ending like oh
problem solved like really easy all we
need is some salt water then everybody'd
be like well [ __ ] and everybody's like
mad about that so i don't know you need
to like hit a happy medium with that and
i'm not really sure it didn't piss me
off too much uh in this movie
but it is a little bit eye rolly you
know what i mean uh but yeah so honestly
um i didn't mind this movie at all it
has like it has some kind of weird laggy
parts and like i said it's weird that
the two
subplots don't really relate to one
another in any way they're just kind of
like separate stories that are going on
the same thing but this is actually uh
really
it seems like a very very it's not so
much this movie but i think like the
novel is really influential you know
particularly like the scene like and
actually this movie like i said uh the
scene with him waking up in the hospital
and everybody being gone was where uh
they got the idea for 28 days later the
opening scene where he's walking around
london and there's nobody there so
that's you know again very influential
on uh filmmakers nowadays so i thought
that was kind of interesting but yeah
it's on tubey uh for free if you want to
watch it like i said the print is not
good so i don't know if someone's
uploaded it to youtube like in a better
quality but the one on 2b is like pretty
rough looking uh it's still watchable
but you know it still doesn't look that
great hopefully they've done a
restoration on it because like i said
this does seem to
be kind of like a movie that has like a
pretty decent cult following at least
you know among british sci-fi fans so uh
let me know if you've seen dave the
trifids from 1962 in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear uh continuing on with monster march
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye